[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon everyone.
I'm Liz Cohen, I'm Dean here
at the Radcliffe Institute,
and I am delighted
to welcome all of you
this afternoon to a lecture
by Jane Kamensky, who
is a professor of
history here at Harvard,
and the Carl and Lily
Pforzheimer Foundation
Director of the
Schlesinger Library.
Members of the
Pforzheimer family
have been steadfast supporters
of the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
and all of Harvard.
And I'm delighted that we
have Gary and Mary Pforzheimer
here with us today in the
audience, so thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
In fact, there are
many supporters
of the library and actually,
the entire Radcliffe
Institute with us today.
I appreciate the
generosity of everyone,
which makes all that we do
here at Radcliffe possible.
And I'm especially
pleased to welcome members
of both of Radcliffe's
Advisory Councils,
our Deans Advisory Council
and the Schlesinger Library
Council.
And I am so glad that you
could all be with us today.
Radcliffe is dedicated to
inquiry and research that
takes place beyond
the curriculum
and across the boundaries of
academic disciplines we bring
together scholars and
scientists, artists
and public intellectuals
from around the world
to share their work
with each other
and with a broad,
interested public like you.
Today we are here to look
at a very different time
from an unconventional angle.
And we could have
no better guide
than Jane Kamensky,
my fellow historian
and Radcliffe colleague.
Jane earned her BA and her
PhD at Yale University.
She taught in the
History Department
at Brandeis for 21 years,
including doing two stints
as Department Chair.
And she survived.
[LAUGHTER]
She also served on the core
faculty in Women's Gender
and Sexuality Studies at
Brandeis while she was there.
During the 2014-15
academic year,
Jane was the Mary L.
Cornille Distinguished
Visiting Professor
at the Newhouse
Center for the Humanities
at Wellesley College.
In 2015, Jane came
to Harvard to serve
as the Faculty Director of
Radcliffe Schlesinger Library
and as a member of the
History Department.
But Jane's connections to
Radcliffe go back even further.
We are pleased that Jane was
a Radcliffe fellow in 2006-07,
and a Bunting fellow
a decade before that.
All of Jane's work from her
scholarship, to her teaching,
to her leadership of
the Schlesinger Library
is marked by innovation,
dynamism, and creativity.
These were the qualities
that greatly inspired us
when Jane interviewed for the
position of Faculty Director.
And in her first year
and a half on the job,
she has brought them to
bear on her ambitious vision
for the library.
Together with Executive
Director Marilyn Dunn,
Jane has undertaken
impressive efforts
to diversify the library's
collections, seeking
to represent a fuller spectrum
of women's experiences
across class, race,
political perspective,
sexual orientation, religious
experience, and more.
And under her
leadership, with the help
of the Schlesinger's
very able staff,
the library is fast
establishing itself
as a pioneer in new ways of
using rich manuscript archives
in teaching and learning.
No surprise that
it is increasingly
being sought out by professors
from across Harvard schools
and departments.
Jane's innovation,
dynamism, and creativity
have likewise established
her as a leading historian
of early America and an
interdisciplinary scholar who
has written on colonial history,
the history of women, gender,
and the family, and the
history of capitalism.
She has also ranged beyond the
conventional by coauthoring
an historical novel and
co-founding a digital journal
called Common-Place: The
Interactive Journal of Early
American Life, and
these are both projects
that she did in partnership with
fellow Harvard historian Jill
Lepore.
Interdisciplinary creativity
marks all of Jane's books,
along with her tireless
research, her eye for just
the right detail and her
elegant writer's voice,
which combines
analytical sophistication
with a dash of playfulness.
In her first book,
entitled Governing
the Tongue: The Politics of
Speech in Early New England,
Jane applied insights from
anthropology and linguistics
to examine speech as a
way of wielding power
in early America.
For Jane's 2008 book,
The Exchange Artist,
she drew on urban design,
architecture, and economics
to tell the story of the Boston
Coffee House, at one time
an important Boston
institution unique to its time
and place in the early republic.
Jane probes this
fascinating local site,
and at the same time
she reveals its key role
in the speculative capitalism
of the early American republic.
In 2007, Jane received a
prestigious New Directions
Grant from the Mellon
Foundation, which
allowed her to train
in a totally new field
to expand her
methodological toolkit.
Jane used the grant to
spend a year in London,
immersing herself in the
study of art history.
That retooling contributed
to Jane's latest book,
A Revolution in Color: The
World of John Singleton
Copley, published last October.
This book delves into
the artistic life
and the tumultuous times
of a man best known
for portraits of prominent
figures like Paul Revere
and Samuel Adams in a
political revolution
about which Copley himself
remained ambivalent.
True to Jane's commitment
at the Schlesinger
to embed considerations
of gender and family
and how we tell
all of our history,
her Copley story locates him
as much in the private life
of his family and household
as in the public life
of 18th century
imperial politics.
If Copley was awash
in ambivalence
about the American
Revolution, there
has been nothing ambivalent
about the critical response
to A Revolution in Color.
It has won the American History
Book Prize of the New York
Historical Society and the
Annibel Jenkins Biography
Prize of the American Society
for Eighteenth-Century Studies.
It was also named a finalist
for PEN's Jacqueline Bograd Weld
Award for Biography,
the Marfield
Prize for Arts Writing, and the
George Washington Book Prize.
I am confident that we
will all benefit from
and greatly enjoy learning more
about A Revolution in Color
from Jane today.
So now please join me
in giving a warm welcome
to Jane Kamensky.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much for that
gracious introduction, Liz.
I feel like there's
nothing anybody now
does not know about me.
[LAUGHTER]
But if anybody wants to hear
about the Hazel Avenue School
in West Orange, New
Jersey, we started
after that, I'll tell
you during the Q&A.
Thank you also to
Alison Franklin
and her colleagues
in communications
who designed this wonderful
image that you see behind
me and did the work of
getting everybody here today.
Jess Brilli, who does
these images for Radcliffe,
really is an artist
in her own right.
I think Copley would very much
approve of her crop there.
Thank you to my many
Harvard colleagues
who I see in the audience
who have contributed
in various ways, not
just from the History
Department but from
around the campus,
from the museums and
the libraries as well,
in various ways to
the final stages
of this book, which took place
after I had come to Harvard.
And then last and
most, to my colleagues
from the Schlesinger library,
who make it an absolute joy
to go to work every day and
who have made this book in ways
that I couldn't have predicted,
and that they couldn't have
predicted, in part a
story about collecting.
And you'll hear a
little bit about that
and I think sense a little
bit of Schlesinger's impact
on A Revolution in Color and my
understanding of Copley's life
towards the end.
So my talk this
afternoon is a circle,
which is a self-conscious
choice about a way
to tell a revolutionary story.
After the American
Revolution and especially
after the French
Revolution a decade later,
the word revolution took on a
new meaning, which is neatly
captured by Hannah Arendt in
this quotation from her book,
On Revolution.
"Revolutions," she
says, "confront
us directly and inevitably
with problems of beginning.
For revolutions, however we
may be tempted to define them,
are not mere changes, but entail
'starting with a new beginning,
a complete change of society.'"
Americans in the time of
the American Revolution
adopted elements
of this definition.
The American Revolution
came to be called
the American Revolution
as early as 1776,
although not frequently
until a generation later,
Jefferson captures
this Arendtian sense
in a famous letter that he
wrote upon his inaugural
in 1801, which he
called of course,
a second American Revolution,
where he said in a letter
to Joseph Priestley,
"We can no longer
say that there is nothing
new under the sun,
for this whole chapter in
the history of man is new."
Jefferson was very modest.
[LAUGHTER]
My talk is a circle beginning
and ending with this picture,
because Copley, like so many
of his generation on both sides
of the Atlantic,
hewed to an older
sense of what revolution
meant, a circular sense based
in Enlightenment science and in
the agricultural calendar that
centered on revolving--
not always revolving to
exactly the same place,
but revolution as
a putting right,
more or less within
a fixed orbit.
Copley embraced in his
work and in his life
a certain degree of innovation,
but not wholesale invention.
He believed, though he
didn't quite put it this way,
in evolution rather
than revolution.
So this is Copley's grand
picture of his own family,
painted during the
revolutionary year of 1776.
It's what was on his
easel that spring.
A diarist noted seeing it in
his painting rooms in April,
unfinished with
the likenesses just
coming into focus,
which means it takes
only a little bit of
poetic license, which
I hope you will grant
me, to place it there
on the 4th of July.
It was the largest
and most complex
picture Copley had ever
painted at that time.
It's about 10 times the size
of his bust-length portraits
of which we're so fond in
the Museum of Fine Arts.
And it contains within
it what we might say
is his whole affective world.
His beloved wife,
Susanna, called
Sukey, her little silk-shod
foot perched on a tuffet
and opposed taken from
Correggio's Madonna of St.
Jerome, which Copley had just
copied over a period of months
in Parma, Italy.
His stern-faced
father-in-law, Richard Clarke,
who made everything about the
picture and about Copley's life
from this point forward at once
both possible and inevitable.
The artist shows himself
behind as the master planner
and in ways you can't
quite see in the resolution
of a reproduction,
just hugely fashionable
and a beautiful
bottle-green velvet cloak.
And he has a trail of his
natural hair in a long queue
romantically going
down his back.
And then four children portrayed
in this newly playful gambling
fashion of the time,
though by the time
Copley painted the picture, one
of them was dead an ocean away
and never having been
seen by his father.
The glimpse of countryside
in the background
is vaguely Italianate.
It closely approximates
the biblical scene,
the biblical backdrop to his
painting The Ascension, which
was done the year
before in 1775 in Rome,
in a kind of mystical
communion between Copley
and Raphael's transfiguration.
He wrote a lot about this.
And also with the
palette of Poussin,
which is everywhere in the
way that the colors deploy
themselves on the canvas.
But if the setting,
the natural setting
in the backdrop of the
family picture is Italian,
the setting of the
painting was London.
So when I say that
the painting was
on Copley's easel on or
about July 4th of 1776,
that easel was set up in
elegant rented quarters
at 12 Leicester Square,
just around the corner
from the studio of
Sir Joshua Reynolds
and near the British Museum.
So the respectable West
End, not the West End
of the actors and the whores.
All spring long in 1776,
people came in and out
of Copley's new home, talking
about the great public topic
of the day, the American
War, debating pamphlets
for and against.
On the day that the diarist
Samuel [? Kirwan ?] stopped by
and saw the family
portrait on the easel,
he carried with him a new
pamphlet entitled An Inquiry
whether the Guilt of the
Present Civil War in America
ought to be imputed to
Great Britain or America.
America was the author's answer.
A few days later,
the diarist picked up
a copy of Richard
Price's Observations
on the Nature of Civil Liberty,
and the Justice and Policy
of the War with America.
Unjust was Richard
Price's answer.
Here's how Copley described the
war with America when he first
learned about the
fighting in Lexington
in April of 1775, news which
took until July of 1775
to reach him in Parma, Italy.
He says, "The flame of Civil
War is now broke out in America,
and I have not
the least doubt it
will rage with the
violence equal to what
it has done in any other
country in any time."
A civil war, as my
colleague David Armitage
has recently and
brilliantly explained,
is in many ways cast is the
opposite of a revolution,
an expression of spasmodic
violence with unpredictable
and usually negative
consequences,
distinctly unprogressive,
unrighteous,
a slipping backwards into
atavism and barbarism,
rather than a new beginning.
And yet civil war
is also the genus
of which revolution, in the
new sense that Copley did not
share, was a particularly
proud species.
At the same time that his Boston
contemporaries were actively
calling a nation into
being, signing a declaration
centered on verbs like
dissolve and assume and publish
and pledge and of
course declare,
Copley was reveling in
a kind of happenstance,
casting himself as in this
quote from a letter written
the next month, not as
the agent of destiny,
but as a recipient of it.
Not as a declarer
of independence,
but a creature of
interdependence,
an enmeshment of calling
and character and kin
that had taken him from the
edge of the British empire
to the center.
And I think so striking in this
last line, reveling in the fact
that he now has no
choice left to make.
So I want to think
about what it means
to look at the world of
the American Revolution,
and even the founding
of the United States
through Copley's eyes and to
see not a revolution in Arendt's
terms and not independence
in Jefferson's terms,
but rather a quite different
mixture of dependence
and independence,
choice and accident.
Copley shows us this blend
in particularly vivid ways,
because he was a painter
whose acuteness of vision
left a lasting material legacy,
including many wonderful things
here on the Harvard campus.
But as the historian
Kathleen DuVal has recently
argued in her towering
book Independence Lost,
centered on the American
Revolution in the Gulf Coast.
"Being independent," and
here I'm quoting DuVal,
"being independent would have
been unwelcome to most people
in 18th century North America.
Men and women
depended on a web of
economic, social, and
political connections
that provided stability
and opportunity even
as they limited complete
freedom of action.
Empires worked in part
because they incorporated
diverse and unequal populations
into a system of beneficial,
if also coercive connections.
For most, advantageous
interdependence
was a more logical
goal," end quote.
Copley's pursuits sometimes
deliberate, sometimes
shambling, of
interdependence, which
was sometimes advantageous
and sometimes disastrous,
are my subject this afternoon.
But I also want
to think with you
about how looking at this
particular, and in many ways
peculiar life story changes
the shape of the whole.
So this story of
interdependence is not
the story we usually tell about
Copley, or indeed about Boston,
where we use Copley to
tell a particular story
and where Copley spent
his first 38 years.
Boston began calling itself
the cradle of American liberty
as early as 1791.
That's the first printed
usage I've found of it.
And by the American
centennial in 1876,
that slogan was everything
but trademarked--
not only part of the
city's sense of itself,
as it still is, but of
its tourist economy,
including the new Museum
of Fine Arts, which
opened in that centennial
year, which opened on July
4th, of 1876,
facing an open plaza
that came in 1882 to be
called Copley Square.
Beginning in that
centennial generation,
Copley's work came
to play a large role
in a national and
civic narrative.
We might say that Copley's Paul
Revere, the inescapable Paul
Revere, was the baby in
the cradle of liberty.
That was a laugh line.
[LAUGHTER]
It's his most iconic
work, arguably
the second most famous face
of revolutionary America
after George Washington,
whom Copley never painted,
which I think was a missed
opportunity for both of them.
He painted this portrait
of the silversmith in 1768,
a year of renewed
political upheaval
in British America following
a period of relative quiet.
The painting is small.
This is the size, of
which you could fit 10
in the family picture.
But it looms large in a
particular liberty narrative
of the American founding, and
has done that work publicly
since it came into public
hands in the 1930s.
If you doubt that we place
this in a liberty narrative,
here's how the
Museum of Fine Arts
displayed Copley's
Revere in 1951,
between the flags
of the United States
and the flag of
the Commonwealth.
This is his Liberty Bowl,
Revere's Liberty Bowl,
also fashioned in
1768 in front of it.
And let me just tell you
as a lapsed Catholic girl,
this is an altar.
[LAUGHTER]
And there's a sort of
chalice-like presentation
of the Liberty Bowl.
And American museology has
changed so much since 1951.
And the new Art of the Americas
wing at the Museum of Fine Arts
really is splendid.
And yet we have hung
onto some of the ways
that Revere is working
sacredly in a narrative
of the American
Revolution, which
includes this quartet of
Copley's receding back
into the distance, Sam
Adams, John Hancock perched
over his account book
as if in 1765 he's
practicing his signature for
the Declaration of Independence.
[LAUGHTER]
11 years later,
Dr. Joseph Warren
waiting to become the martyr
of Bunker Hill and Mercy
Otis Warren waiting to
become a generation, hence
the first historian of
the American Revolution.
The gallery is called
Revolutionary Boston.
My colleague Jill
Lepore has called
these the Patriot Superfriends.
[LAUGHTER]
So a particular story
of Boston and its role
in the founding of a particular
story of the nation with Copley
pressed into its service,
when in fact Copley
grew up in a very
different Boston
with a very different set of
connections and belongings.
So this is a detail from
a map that is reprinted
throughout the 18th century.
This is a 1769 printing,
it's first printed in 1722.
And the whole map
performs for the harbor.
East is the north of this map.
Just as 18th century Boston
performed for the harbor,
and as indeed every
American seaport did.
These were second tier
British seaports, not
an incipient Acela corridor.
Copley lived in his
early years in one
of these ramshackle houses
on the north side of the Long
Wharf.
It's a very plebeian
space, where his mother
sold tobacco on the
first floor and family
possessions and living space
was in a sort of second floor
lean-to.
He was the child of immigrants,
which was not unusual
in the world of the 18th
century Atlantic, which
was a very mobile
place, but is quite
unusual in the world
of New England, which
was by then a very long-lived
settler colonial population.
His parents were
both from Ireland,
in the second substantial
wave of Irish immigration
to Boston in the 1730s.
His mother was sort of a
Tennessee Williams character
of fallen gentry
from County Claire,
and his father in the
way of such tales,
was a ne'er do
well from Limerick.
In this oceanic
world, if we think
about where all these
ships were going,
and this is a question
that we can answer
by looking at newspapers,
which tracked ships coming in
and ships going out,
they we're going
to places like Halifax,
Jamaica, and Barbados,
which were the three
most frequent trading
partners of Boston to
England, especially to London
and to Bristol, and more
often to West Africa
than to Philadelphia
or New York.
So if we're doing
that Saul Steinberg
cartoon, that famous
cartoon of the view
of the world from
9th Avenue, the view
of the world from Copley's
Boston was closer to Jamaica
than it was to Philadelphia.
There's a sort of famous
historian's canard
that at the time of the
first Continental Congress,
more of the participants
than that Congress
had been to London than
had been to Philadelphia,
which of course made
sense in their world.
London was the only
capital city recognized
by all of these disparate
provinces, which
in British North America at
the time of Copley's birth
numbered not 13, but 21,
and after 1763, numbered 26.
So that's the landscape
of America for him,
is 26 polities.
There is no logical
subgroup of 13
in the world of his childhood.
And the place that they
call home is London.
London called home even into
the post-revolutionary American
Atlantic.
Another reason to focus
on the oceanic nature
of Copley's world besides
connections and trade
is I think that oceans remind
us of a certain kind of drift
of fatalism, of the bobbing
cork of an individual
on a sea of life--
in Copley's case, a kind
of Anglican providentialism
that's emblemetized in
the no choice left quote
that I showed you
before, but also
in print in this first sentence
of a loyalist narrative
in 1782, in which our hero,
Lieutenant James Moody says,
"The choice and
plan, it would seem,
have seldom much influence
in determining either men's
characters or their conditions.
These are usually the
result of circumstances
utterly without our control."
The importance of this sense
of accidents and contingency
to biography is true
to the whole genre.
I think one of the
reasons it's worth
looking at history at the
level of individual life
is it reminds us that
while we as historians,
as social scientists traffic
in patterns and choices,
accidents more
than plans make up
the people who make up history.
And this was a truism
of Copley's life
and of his American
Revolution as well.
So I'm going to sketch a
couple of tiers of accident,
starting with the personal.
I've said that he was the
child of Irish immigrants.
He was also a child who was,
for much of his early years,
raised by a widowed mother
without brothers or sisters.
This is a very
distinctive condition
in the rabbit hutch of
18th century America,
where especially in the
North, families of 8 or 10,
12 children are the norm.
The last time I know
his father was alive,
Copley was three years old.
His mother was as
young as 30 and didn't
remarry for a long
time, which is itself
interesting and
unrecoverable to me.
It's atypical of the time.
So the two of them
shifting together,
this very young boy and
this widowed trader woman
on the Long Wharf for
a long period of time,
I think among the
accidents of character,
it makes him a watchful person.
It's a rough and dangerous
space, the Long Wharf, seamen
and stevedores
and the people who
serviced them in all of the
ways that they needed servicing.
Another accident--
I didn't want to say
whores a second time in
the same talk at Harvard,
but here I've done it.
[LAUGHTER]
Another biographical
accident that
winds up being very
important, and you're
wondering how Cotton Mather
is going to enter this story
and here it is, is that when
Copley's mother, Mary Singleton
Copley, remarried in 1748 when
Jack Copley, she called him,
was 10, it happened to be
to a highly trained artisan
from London named Peter Pelham,
also an immigrant and also
with Irish connections.
There's no surviving
image of Pelham,
but this is the
mezzotint engraving
that he did of
Cotton Mather soon
after Pelham got to America.
He came to America, he
got Mather to sit to him,
a London-trained portraitist
was a good thing,
and then Mather
did the best thing
Mather could have possibly
done for Pelham's career, which
was to die.
[LAUGHTER]
And he marketed this mezzotint
print in Boston, at which point
mezzotint was new enough, which
meant that Pelham's skills were
distinctive enough
that he had to explain
in the newspapers what
this form of engraving was.
So he got a stepfather
who happened
to be an artisan, really
quite on the cutting edge.
Another accident,
both happy and sad,
is that the couple began to
have children right away.
So Jack, at age 10, got a very
beloved little brother, Henry,
known as Harry in this
little candlelight portrait
on the other side
of your screen.
And there was a
short-lived little girl
named Helena Maria, who died
before her first birthday.
What's interesting to
me about Helena Maria
is that is a very
high church name
for an Anglican on the
eastern rim of the Atlantic.
I don't know whether
there's crypto-Catholicism
in their background.
And then the last
biographical accident
that matters for this
part of my story today
is that three years after this
blended family came together
and probably after three years
in which a 10-year-old would
be put to work in his
father's artisanal enterprise,
Peter Pelham died,
so that Copley
has a male provider in his
life, maybe for the first three
years of his life and then
for a three-year window
in his early
adolescence, leaving
behind a vulnerable young
family with a 12-year-old
to 13-year-old Copley
as the male provider,
and the rudiments of this very
particular and peculiar trade.
So an accident that
meant that Copley
had to get to work very
early, and that the work
he had to get to work in was
the work of artisanship and art.
This is one of the earliest
surviving Copley canvases
from 1754.
It's at the Museum of Fine Arts.
It's in store, they don't hang
it, you can probably see why.
I want to say just a couple
of things about this picture
before moving on to a different
type of accidental shaping.
So it's a very ambitious picture
in a lot of ways for somebody
who is trying out his hand.
It's a copy of a
European print, which is
a copy of a European painting.
And its mythological subject
is Galatea riding the waves.
Like Boston itself, it
depicts an oceanic world.
Several of Copley's
earliest paintings
are these reproductions
of reproductions
of European seascapes.
It's very large.
It's two Reveres.
So from the perspective
of a 16-year-old trying
to fashion himself
as an artist, that
represents a significant
investment in materials,
as well as an
investment in time.
And keep in mind that
the canvas, the brushes,
the pigments, the oils,
the recipes, everything
but the frame would have
come imported from London.
The other thing that I find
kind of importantly poignant
about this image is how
faint provincial echoes
of a very distant
cosmopolitan world
meant something, so
that seeing the print
and imagining the colors and
knowing something of not only
Ovid's Galatea but
that Handel had
remade Galatea into the most
popular piece of secular music
in 18th century
London, how all of that
in some game of
telephone way found
its way into Copley's Boston.
So 1754 at the age of 16,
here is an artisan's child
painting himself into the
world of British empire
and trying to
imagine it in color.
I think it's metaphorically
quite true to Copley's hunger
and what you could and couldn't
do in the Boston of his time.
The other important
and accidental context
that he shared with an
entire generation and not
just fatherless boys
on the wharf in Boston
was that he lived
in a world of war.
And in this sense, the
American Revolution
wasn't so revolutionary
after all,
because European imperial wars
played out in North America
were statistically
the norm of his life.
He lived for 77 years.
45 of those years
were spent in wartime
where England, France, and
North America were all involved.
The first of these four
wars of Copley's life
broke out the year after he was
born, though he couldn't have
possibly noted, he was born
at the end of the longest
peace for a century.
This is the Second
Hundred Years' War,
as some historians call it.
And significantly, I've
said that 1754, 1753
are his first surviving works.
It was a happy accident
in ways for his career
that he came to
artistic adulthood
and to the need for
a manly competence,
as people at his time
would have put it, as the
Seven Years' War was making
Boston a provisioning
hub of the Northern frontier
of this great global war.
The Seven Years' War killed
an awful lot of people,
not just around
North America and not
just around the Atlantic,
but around the globe.
But it also made great fortunes,
and it brought the empire
to Boston in a way that
had never happened before.
The number of
redcoats on the ground
go from scores to hundreds to
thousands to tens of thousands
in a period of about two years.
And as the empire collected
in that provisioning hub,
there were people
who had fortunes
to have their portraits painted
like John Hancock's Uncle
Thomas.
That's where his
fortune originates,
is in provisioning ships for the
Northern frontier of the Seven
Years' War.
And there were soldiers
and other men attached
to the British army, who wanted
to have their portraits painted
in the cloth of empire.
So I put quite a lot
of weight in my book
on some of these quite formulaic
early military paintings, which
are not especially
interesting art historically.
They're kind of
much of a muchness.
And yet in terms of building
Copley's strategic world,
showing these men in the
scarlet fabric of empire
and contributing
to the gift economy
where a portrait went
to Hancock to thank him
for his generosity,
were inordinately
important to a young
artist who wanted
to break the frame of
provincial Boston, which
he called this frozen region.
He knew about today, right?
[LAUGHTER]
The strategies, these
paintings tested the networks
they provided, the
skills that they'd built,
all became very
important to Copley
in the post Seven
Years' War world.
This is another one, still in
private hands of Colonel Jacob
Fowle.
This is painted at the very
end of the Seven Years' War.
The one I just showed you was
painted near the beginning
so that these red-coated
images are carrying him
through the entirety of this
war, and indeed a bit beyond.
What I wanted to tell you
about this picture is,
this is a very
old style uniform.
It's an older man who has not
served in the Seven Years' War,
but served in the
war before that.
And yet the new war made
you come and take out
the uniform of the old war
and show your connection
to the lineage that looks
backwards over the Hanoverian
Arc of time, not
forwards anticipating
some American Revolution, which
is literally unimaginable.
The most important
of Copley's redcoats
over the course of
his entire career,
both historically
and biographically,
is this dramatic three quarter
length history portrait
of General Thomas Gage, who was
the commander of British forces
in all of North
America, and who came
to Boston in the fall of 1768
to settle an occupying army
into its winter quarters.
Because that visit was
so closely documented,
we know almost
exactly when Copley
painted this picture, which
was within months, if not
within weeks of the moment
that he painted Paul Revere.
So when we're thinking
about his world,
we have to think of those
things going together.
We also have to
think of the fact
that Copley at this point,
so 1768 in the Gage portrait
and 1769 in this
document, which shows
all the attendees of the annual
commemoration of the Stamp Act
riots by the Sons of Liberty.
So in this document,
Copley is listed
among the Sons of Liberty.
This is Copley here, the
Adams cousins up there,
Hancock as usual, first under
the Hs and Revere over there.
So in some social and
political network,
he is a soft liberty man
as well as the painter
of the occupying army.
Some historians in the
past have taken this
as a particular deafness
in Copley's character.
I think it shows us that the
sides and the social worlds
were really still very enmeshed
and not very far apart at all,
because these men also
sat down and drank
with Gage's adjutants.
The revolution is not
after all yet come.
Copley continues
painting red coats
in the wake of the Boston
so-called massacre in 1770.
This is Captain John Montresor,
who's one of Gage's adjutants.
Copley paints him
in New York in 1771.
Following that military nexus
from the Seven Years' War
into the early stages
of the imperial crisis
and still broadening out these
networks of men in red cloaks.
This is at Detroit
Institute of Arts now,
and it's a really
striking painting.
So a counter-factual question
would be without the Seven
Years' War and the military and
social and economic connections
it forged, I don't know that
Copley would have begun by late
1764 or early 1765 to ponder
the question that would dog him
for the next decade and return
in some ways for the rest
of his life, which was how
would his work stand up
to the competition at home--
which is to say, in London--
and ought he to follow it there?
This of course,
is the famous Boy
with a Flying Squirrel,
which hangs at the MFA
in a kind of pride
of place, though not
so prideful as the
much lesser Revere.
Copley sent it to London
in September of 1765
in the immediate
wake of the Stamp Act
riots, which he bemoaned even
though he was a liberty man,
more contradiction.
He was painting and planning
at that entire year,
if not longer, and building
up a network of sea captains
and military men
and other conduits
to get it from the Long
Wharf to the Annual Spring
Exhibition of the
Society of Artists
of Great Britain, a society
and exhibition program that
was itself a kind of
artistic nationalism
catalyzed by the
Seven Years' War.
So I think we might see this
too as a kind of military
painting with Boy with a Flying
Squirrel draped literally
in the scarlet cloth of empire.
So I painted Copley
largely as a creature
of drift, which was how
he experienced himself
and in many ways
continued to be.
But he did one very planful
and absolutely critical
thing in his life, which was
to marry very well and very
deliberately in
the fall of 1769,
about a year after
painting Revere and Gage,
and just a couple of months
after that Sons of Liberty
dinner.
We know that he was tactical
about marriage because he wrote
about how hard it
was to put it off,
how hard it was to husband
his energies for his craft
and stay a bachelor to
the advanced age of 28.
He wound up staying a bachelor
three years longer than that.
So even though we
never know, is somebody
aware of the
demographic average that
is the average age of
marriage, he was aware
that he was getting a
little long in the tooth.
We know it was a love
marriage, or at least it
unfolds on paper
like a love marriage.
Love marriage being the
new fashion of the day,
would have been considered
quite preposterous
even 100 years before.
But it was also a tactical
marriage, love and money
went together, and
maybe even still do.
A huge climb for him
socially and economically,
when we teach the marriage
plot as the common plot
of 18th century fiction,
I think we too often
forget that for every
woman who married down,
there is a man who married up.
And that man was Copley.
So he married Susanna
Farnham Clarke--
you've already met her in
silk in the family portrait--
and gains in her set of family
connections an enormous amount
of economic wherewithal
and new interdependencies
and dependencies, some of
which he could imagine and some
of which he couldn't.
So a kind of independence,
Copley gained the wherewithal
to purchase land, which
was the only way someone
could think of
themselves as independent
in the 18th century.
This is why there
were traditionally
property qualifications required
to be able to cast a vote.
Only if you held
real property did
you have the capacity to
have an independent opinion
politically.
So this is a detail taken
from here on this map
so that you can see
that Copley's holdings
in downtown Boston were large
enough to be labeled as a map
feature, as Copley's hill.
He put together about
14 contiguous acres
of downtown Boston, going
from in the present just
next to the Bulfinch
gold-domed statehouse all the
way to Charles
Street, and then going
north all the way back to
what was then the riverfront.
So an enormous
gentleman farm, which
he describes at great length
in a series of letters.
When he is having it
renovated in 1770, 1771,
he calls it Mount Pleasant.
He cultivates potatoes, he does
the whole gentleman farming
thing.
He also gained from
his marriage, children
born at very regular intervals,
the kind of regular intervals
that Sukey could
only have because she
was a fancy enough lady
that she was employing
a wet nurse, which we know
from his letters that she was.
The first daughter Betsy is
born almost exactly nine months
after the marriage,
but not one day sooner.
[LAUGHTER]
And a young John Jr., who they
called Jackie about 18 months
after that, and a daughter Mary,
called Polly, about 18 months
after that.
In fact, one of the reasons
that Copley wound up still
here in the fateful fall of 1773
is because Suki was pregnant
again.
Copley also became a slaveholder
upon his marriage, another kind
of interdependence that his
growing liberty and capacity
to exercise independent
judgment, put him
into the rank of Boston's
slaveholding classes,
which were not as small
as the cradle of liberty
likes to suggest.
This was an irony,
this combination
of slavery and
liberty that was much
remarked upon by
anti-revolutionary forces
at the time.
Most famously Samuel Johnson in
1775, writing, "How is that we
hear the loudest
yelps for liberty
among the drivers of Negroes?"
There were at least three
bondspeople in Copley's retinue
at Mount Pleasant in the
immediate wake of his wedding--
a boy called Snap who was
probably from the Caribbean
where Sukey's
father had business;
a girl called Lucy
whom Copley sold
in 1771 into the Pepperell
family whose new mistress was
therefore the daughter
of Isaac Royall,
so he joins the Harvard
slavery story that way;
and an older boy or young man
named Cato in that classisizing
way of naming slaves in the
18th century, who we know about
because he married in Boston in
the post-revolutionary period,
able to take his
independence in a way
that he couldn't beforehand,
and left a record that way.
We don't know who
this man is who
Copley painted in 1778, by
which point he was in London.
It's an oil sketch,
a study picture
for the figure at the apex
of Watson and the shark.
It stayed in the family, this
oil sketch, into the 1860s,
was known in the catalog
that sold the family
pictures in 1862 as the
head of a favorite Negro.
So it is a familiar
of the family.
It's also a very
familiar portrait,
which is one of the things that
the showing of teeth means.
I don't know whether Copley had
black servants in his retinue
in London.
They would likely not have been
enslaved after the ambiguity
that the Somerset
decision of 1772
cast on slavery in Britain.
However, and I'll
come back to this
when I close my circle
in a little bit,
slavery stayed important
in Copley's story
from cradle to grave.
Copley's marriage also provoked
him to take for the first time
a trip abroad in the summer of
1771, which is what he called
it when he went to New York.
[LAUGHTER]
London is home and
New York is abroad.
And among the three dozen
paintings he churned out there
in a mere six months--
and Copley's known for his
slowness, by the way,
so this is frantic--
is this spectacular likeness of
Colonel Gage's wife, Margaret
Kemble Gage, which Copley called
the greatest female portrait
of his life, and which
certainly deserves
that title, the greatest female
portrait of his life to date,
it was 1772 when he said this.
It's in the tiny, tiny
Timken Museum in San Diego,
it is worth the trip.
But if Copley gained
strategically love and land
and slaves and travel, he
also gained accidentally
a very close connection to tea.
Tea was one of the commodities
that Copley's father-in-law
had made his fortune
trafficking in.
And in 1773 when Britain
passed the Tea Act,
making it possible to sell
East India Company tea directly
in the colonies
through consignees
for the first time
at prices low enough
to compete with smugglers,
Copley's father-in-law
felt that he was very lucky
in getting one of the licenses
to sell it in Boston.
And it turned out of course,
not to be so lucky after all.
So as the tea ships
approached Boston,
mobs set upon Copley's
father-in-law's house
on School Street,
nearly destroying it.
And even before the dumping
of the tea, Copley's male kin
were holed up in
the British fortress
at Castle Island for
their own safety,
threatened daily in
the newspapers with tar
and feathering and worse.
And when the tea was dumped
into Boston Harbor on December
16th of 1773, a plurality
of those 342 tea chests
belonged to Richard
Clarke, or it
belonged to the East India
Company in consignment
to Richard Clarke.
Copley's kin became personae
non grata after that moment.
And it turned out in the
wake of the Tea Party
that his marriage was the
most important decision
in his life in a very different
way than he had anticipated,
which is that he married
his politics and ultimately
his citizenship.
For all of these reasons, family
and war and calling and empire,
and with only a little
smattering of ideology,
Copley's revolution led him home
to the place where the family
portrait sat on the easel
in the spring of 1776,
while many of his
former Boston neighbors,
including some men like
Samuel Adams and John Hancock,
whom he had painted and then
grown utterly to despise,
had begun drafting
a document declaring
the independence of a nation
and a notion of America
that Copley would never
see and never share.
Lived and read about
and seen from London,
Copley's American Revolution
was Britain's American War.
And no choices left--
war, and soon a losing war.
It's one of the great
ironies of Copley's career
that the war with
America remained
his context and his subject for
much of the rest of his life.
At first in the 1770s
and early 1780s,
it was a kind of calling card.
And then it was a millstone
for a formerly American artist
now at the center of the
London establishment.
Much of Copley's art
in London was the art
of winning by
losing, where he was
on the one hand able to paint
as he could not possibly have
done in British North America.
The pictures got large and
busy and complex, public art
with different kinds
of public patronage.
But the dilemma of
painting public art
in London in the
1770s and 1780s was
how to paint the irresistible
subject of the day
when Britain was losing.
And this became Copley's niche.
The American War, however
much he and his family
had tried to escape it, was
his great and defining subject,
his claim to academic
bona fides in the higher
reaches of British art
and to public attention.
The American War is the subject,
to one degree and another,
of all of his great
London history pictures,
including Watson and
the Shark, The Death
of the Earl of Chatham, and the
enormous and very belated Siege
and Relief of Gibraltar,
which I'll show you just
in a flicker in a moment.
And I'm happy to talk about
any of those in the Q&A,
but I want to talk in
a little bit of depth
about just one, the third
and I think the greatest
of Copley's American
War paintings, which
celebrates a battle
and even a theater
of the American Revolution
that you have likely
never considered.
So this is a painting called
The Death of Major Pearson.
It celebrates an event that
happened in January of 1781,
and it's displayed
publicly in 1784.
It's the battle of Jersey--
not New Jersey, but
the Isle of Jersey.
It featured no North
American combatants, which
was important to Copley's war.
The Americans were not
necessarily villains,
though the British are heroes.
In fact, it featured no
official combatants at all.
It's a kind of
unofficial skirmish
by a rump garrison of
French legionnaires
who leave Brittany and go
raiding on the Isle of Jersey,
resulting in an inglorious
15-minute long battle,
after which the
governor of the island
is court martialed
for his dereliction
in allowing it to happen
in the first place.
A gallant young
major died in it,
whom nobody had ever heard of.
This fellow in the
middle, Francis Pearson,
dying so beautifully in this
image of martial sacrifice
and Christian heroism.
Copley painted it
over two years,
and it was exhibited after
the Peace of Paris, which
created the United States, and
ratified that his America, that
seamless oceanic world of 26
colonies, was gone for good.
In one of the most striking
passages in the painting,
Copley celebrates what
he and others of his day
called not just liberty,
but British liberty
or English liberty.
Avenging Pearson's
death is a servant
of African descent shown in
a dramatic blue not uniform,
but servant's livery, a sort
of military style livery.
I've traced him from
the documentary record
and found that this man is one
of two people in real life--
IRL, as my kids say--
someone who was born
enslaved in the Carolinas
and fled behind British
lines to work for the British
in the North American
continental theater,
and then followed his
officer to other places
on the British front lines,
including this odd Eastern
Front in the middle of Jersey.
He wound up in London as a
hairdresser, a skilled trade
that would have been all
but inconceivable for him
as an enslaved man in the
Southern parts of the United
States, I think one of
the ways that Copley
shows in several of these
American War paintings
that Britain is winning
the war for liberty
even as it's losing the
war for its rebel colonies.
The other striking
passage in the painting
is the presence of
women and children
in a battle scene,
which is really
quite anomalous in the
genre of battle painting.
And this little group of
noncombatants fleeing in terror
at lower right is in fact,
Copley's family, his wife,
his son, and his baby daughter,
all sort of emblematic exiles
and their maidservant
over here, emblematic
exiles in something of the
way that they were in life.
So I'll close my
circle by talking
about the question of how
much he sees and doesn't see
about the future,
and how much we see
and don't see about the future.
In that same letter
from August of 1775
where he's saying
how relieved he
is that he has no choice left,
he comments about "how short
a way we penetrate into
the secrets of futurity?"
He's pretentious.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not just 18th century,
he's the sort of pretentious,
ambitious fellow.
And I think one of the
things that a close view
of the world of revolution
through ambivalent men
like Copley reminds us of is
that it is very different to be
looking at history forward
than looking at it backward.
This is especially
true of the world
of the American
Revolution, which
has come to take on in
retrospect within the United
States an aura of destiny
that also gives it
a kind of tidiness and
linearity, a mythic founding.
Like the rest of us,
Copley saw into the future
both well and poorly.
For example, at the time he
wrote this letter in the summer
after Lexington, he was certain
that when the bleeding stopped,
quote, "the Americans will be
a free, independent people."
He did not mean this
as a compliment.
But nobody at the time
thought that America
would win, certainly
not George Washington.
Yet as he went on to
explain, the strife
would not end with independence.
The country, he said, would
be torn in pieces twice--
first by the quarrel
with Great Britain
till it is a distinct
government, and then
with civil discord till
time has settled it
into some permanent form.
Whether that form would be,
he said, free or despotic
was beyond the reach of
human wisdom to decide.
And I think we're
actually still waiting.
[LAUGHTER]
Pictorially, Copley
grasped the future poorly.
As I've said, he hung onto the
American War much too long,
in part because he painted much
too slowly and deliberately.
So this is that last Great
American War picture, The Siege
and Relief of Gibraltar.
It's the largest picture he
ever painted, 18 by 25 feet.
It hangs in Guildhall
in London right now.
It was painted for Guildhall.
It was so much too big that
they had to cut it down
to fit in its
purpose-built gallery.
And it took him so
long to paint it
that it was not exhibited
until almost 10 years
after the siege was
broken, by which point
all of the eyes of
England had moved on
to the next imperial war, to
painting Nelson and thinking
about Napoleon,
which Copley missed.
It is an accident of his life
that he missed both Nelson
and Washington, who were the
great subjects of either side
of their Atlantic for the day,
and hung on to what for Britons
was a mercifully fading memory
of the loss of Americans
and his own losses, too.
But I think the
realm in which he
was most deliberate and planful
and successful about futurity
was the realm of family.
He said during his grand tour
that launching his family
into the great world
with reputation
was what he was doing it for,
and that he did very well.
So this is his son,
the little fleeing
boy at the edge of the
death of Major Pearson,
all grown up as Lord Lyndhurst
Baron and Lord High Chancellor,
peer of the new
creation, painted here
as the aristocrat
and man of state
he had become by the 1830s.
Copley's son visited the
young United States in 1796
to see if it was safe for
the women and children.
He thought briefly about
building a Western estate there
with hundreds of acres for
his parents and their dotage,
and then decided after
all, it was dicey.
He wrote, "If you want to
be cured of your Jacobinism,
come to Philadelphia."
[LAUGHTER]
Copley's daughter
Betsy also succeeded
in some ways more grandly,
and in others more darkly.
She too, was married late
and tactically at the ripe
age of 30 back to America,
not Copley's America,
and back to Boston.
Like her father,
she also married
into slavery, a slaving fortune
in the demerara sugar trade
with the planter,
Gardiner Greene.
They lived on Beacon
Hill in grand style.
Their money, Greene's
slaving wealth,
is what funded the rise of the
son into the ranks of lawyerdom
and then the peerage,
and also what
saved the Copley's from
penury in his declining years.
Betsy and her husband
Gardiner Greene
had a large staff of
servants including
several free African-Americans,
and at least one
enslaved named Harry, who was
also Gardiner Greene's son.
When Gardiner
Greene died in 1832,
his will manumitted
Harry, which I
think means that Harry
Greene was one of the last,
if not the last
enslaved man in Boston,
living about two
blocks down from where
The Liberator was published.
So slavery at the core
of Copley's ability
to self-make and self-sustain
from first to last.
Betsy Copley, Gardiner
Greene's wife,
lived for decades after
her husband passed.
Here she is in a studio portrait
taken in Boston in 1862.
I love the parrot.
[LAUGHTER]
And this matters in
a variety of ways,
because she saved the
archive that wound up
enabling me to tell this story.
It's at the Massachusetts
Historical Society.
And also because she made
sure to get the pictures.
And it is her collecting efforts
that brought Boy with a Flying
Squirrel and The Ascension, The
Izzards, Watson and the Shark,
and the family picture
to the United States.
Which we might call
a repatriation but
they would call an expatriation.
The family portrait hangs
today in the West Wing
of the National Gallery,
set very appropriately
alongside the works of Joshua
Reynolds, Thomas Gainsborough,
and others of
Copley's peers who,
like him, were British
artists from cradle to grave.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- My name is Arthur Grove.
I'm one of a number of the
people in your audience
who are museum guides at
the Museum of Fine Arts.
I'm very pleased
to read your book,
to hear you speak.
You combined the opportunity to
have both an educational point
of view and a very
entertaining way
of presenting your material.
I wanted to ask one question
that I was unaware of until I
read your book.
And that is the dispute
between Paul Revere
and his half brother,
Harry or Henry Pelham.
Which when you go in to see Paul
Revere and look to the right,
you can appreciate the
fact that these two
people who should
have been good friends
were not such good friends.
- Yeah, thank you for that.
Revere and his family
and Copley and his family
are part of the
same world of men
who work with their
hands and their heads.
We know that Revere borrows
some of the specialized press
implements that
allows him to run off
his engravings from
the Pelham family,
probably a way that Mary Pelham
monetized some of her husband's
legacy by lending it to Revere.
We also know that
Revere was a thief.
Just in the totally
expected way that
in a world before copyright,
the way that you took images
was to borrow bits and pieces.
Revere couldn't
draw worth a dime,
but he knew well what to copy.
And when the Boston so-called
massacre [CLEARS THROAT]
occurred in March of 1770,
Revere working closely with
the firebrand--
Boston printers Benjamin
Edes and Moses Gill,
knew that an image to make that
incendiary event come alive
for readers was very important.
And it so happened that
Harry Pelham had drawn one
and was rushing his own
engraving into print.
Revere had better channels
and Revere got the engraving
into print first.
And Pelham wrote him just
an excoriating letter
saying, how could you?
Pelham had staked
a fortune on being
able to produce this
thing an earn out.
And Revere took and
used his better networks
and some slightly
better details.
Revere changes the name of the
custom-house to butcher's hall.
So that very iconic image
of a world coming apart,
Revere's massacre image, which
until George Washington's
portrait begins to circulate,
is the most famous image
of the revolutionary
project in the world,
is stolen from
Copley's half brother.
I think it's incontrovertible.
And Harry Pelham was
an immoderate guy,
he was a hothead.
And he hated Revere after that.
And I don't know what
Copley thought of Revere,
but I think he would have
picked up his half brother's
side of this feud.
He wrote and said, give me
the pieces of the press back.
- In 1770, Harry Pelham
was only 21 years old.
Paul Revere was 36 years old.
So there was a great
deal of difference.
Harry Pelham was trying
to start his career.
Paul Revere was already
an established--
It's It's not very nice. of him.
- --successful man.
But my question I wanted to
ask was, I have your quote,
I'm not going to
read the whole thing.
But Harry Pelham's
letter to Paul Revere,
and I'm just going to read
the last line from your book.
"I will leave you to
reflect upon and consider
of one of the most dishonorable
actions you could well
be guilty of."
Now the question is, did Revere
respond to that criticism?
- Pelham saved letters.
That's how I've
got so much that's
so good to work with
in textual form.
I can't imagine that Pelham
wouldn't have saved and indeed
publicized Revere's response.
So my guess is that
Revere did not respond,
but the response
has not survived.
- Thank you very much.
- I'm Sasha Tipper.
I'm a professor emeritus from
Nichols College in English.
I have a few trivial
questions to ask.
First of all, I'm interested
in wives and mothers.
And I'm also interested in--
I wonder whether his
mother, you talked
about and the two
fathers' influence.
Did the mother have any
influence upon him at all?
Was he a spoilt child,
or was it the poverty
that put an end to that?
And also, you didn't
talk much about the wife.
Why was she willing
to go to London
with her husband, for instance?
- Thank you.
Some of my best friends
are wives and mothers.
[LAUGHTER]
And both of those women matter
tremendously to this story.
So I think his mother
brought everything of culture
that he would have
known to his world
until Peter Pelham joined their
household when Copley was 10.
She came from a beautiful
house in County Claire,
it was on sale at the
time of my writing
my book for 1.3 million Euros
in a kind of Gothicized version.
She had the education of a
daughter of the landed gentry.
We know she has a
very fine lady's hand.
She has a much better
education than her son does.
When her first husband's
estate was probated,
it's an estate worth
about 97 pounds, which
would be on the lower
end of accumulated
property in the colonies.
And yet it in it is a looking
glass and a suite of six
framed prints and pictures.
So I think there is a
hunger for culture that
must come from her in a way that
I can't see in his early life,
but I can see her shaping
hand in his later life.
He was also-- and forgive
me for saying something
so entirely [INAUDIBLE] he
was incredible mama's boy.
When he goes to London,
he takes the grand tour,
launches from
London, and travels
with another really
sort of third tier
British painter
named George Carter.
And George Carter writes
this picturesque narrative
of their travels in which
he says about Copley,
"He has been too long the
hero of each little tale."
[LAUGHTER]
I take that to be first of all,
it's a kind of cliche, right?
The country bumpkin
in the cosmopolis.
It's also a story about
Boston, upon small enough
that Copley was the most
talented person within 3,000
miles.
But I think it's
also a family story,
making much of that he took from
his household into his career.
And Carter goes
into, there's never
a plate has passed that he
doesn't take the biggest
chicken leg first, or take three
before everybody else has one,
that he sighs and
swoons over the bedding.
I think he is much
doted on, and I
think that is a shaping
influence of his character.
In many ways, the
question of the wife,
I think there's an interesting
tension between the ways
that her identity
is covered by his
and the way that everything
about 18th century history
would lead us to expect.
The custom and law
of coverture is she
loses even her name, her
ability to own property.
But in other ways he
is covered by her.
It's her political identity.
It's the shaping hand
of her kin network
that takes him to London
and keeps him there.
You know, she goes to
London because the going
has gotten so hot that he
really can't come back.
By the time she goes
to London, Boston
is under siege by
the Patriot forces,
the new Continental Army.
They are some of the
last loyalists out.
He is not an exile,
but she is an exile.
And that politically
comes from her father,
the desire to stay
in London is his.
So she goes there in flight,
not without his connivance.
And she stays there because
it remains his home.
Her kin all come to London
as loyalists during the war,
and all return and take up
their lives and fortunes
in the new United States,
which as my colleague MiaMaya
Jasanoff has written
about, is one of the things
that loyalists did.
Some of them resumed.
And Copley chose not to, and
she was governed by that choice.
So it's an excellent question.
- Hi.
I'm Sarah Friedman, and
I had a question about,
you mentioned that in 1831,
that Henry was manumitted.
- 1832, yeah.
- 1832.
I was wondering, because
that kind of surprised me.
Because we know at
least the 1790 census,
there are no slaves.
- And never again.
- Right, so were
you able to find
in the 1820 census, 1830
census under that household,
was he listed?
Was there anything else
that corroborated this other
than the word manumitted?
- So I think that this is a
lacunae in our understanding
of slavery in the North
where as you know,
slavery is abolished by
custom and legal precedent
in Massachusetts in
1783, with the freedom
suit that Quock Walker brings.
And from 1790 forward, there is
never again an enslaved person
censused as enslaved.
And yet manumissions continue.
I think if I had
Gardiner Greene here,
Gardiner Greene
would say, and Harry
is interviewed in various
Boston publications
when Gardiner Greene dies
as his faithful man Harry.
It's not said that it's his
son, but it's very clear.
He lives as if a free man.
And I think what
this means is when
the census taker comes
to your door you say,
oh, it's a free man.
He's living as if a free man.
There is a bequest
that Gardiner Greene
makes to his mulatto
Harry in the will,
to establish him in
a house of his own
which is 10 feet by 10
feet, a tenement worth $400.
Gardiner Greene's household
is worth $1.5 million in 1832.
So I think the gray area
between bondage and freedom
lasts longer, is grayer than our
conventional stories of the end
of slavery in Boston allow.
He's very late.
He's after gradual
abolition has ended slavery
in most of the North,
even for the longest-lived
after this date, and
you have to reach 25.
I just think we would
have to look places other
than the census
records to find it out.
- So please join me in
giving a round of applause
to Jane for her
wonderful lecture.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]